allow me to uh to start this talk with a
question to everyone you know that all
over the world people fight for their
freedom fight for the rights some battle
oppressive governments others battle
oppressive societies which battle do you
think is harder allow me to try to
answer this question in the few coming
minutes let me take you back to years
ago in my life it was a bit time with my
son God Buddha he was five at the time
after finishing his bedtime rituals he
looked at me and he asked her question
mommy are we bad people I was shocked
why do you say such thing Aboudi any
other day I noticed some bruises in his
face when he came from school who didn't
tell me what happened he was ready to
tell two boys hit me today in school
they told me we saw your mom and
Facebook you and your mom should be put
in jail I've never been afraid to tell a
Buddha anything I've been always proud
women of my achievements but those
questioning eyes of my son with my
moment of truth when it all came
together
you see I'm assigned a woman who been
put to jail for driving a car in a
country where women are not supposed to
drive cars just for giving me his car
keys my own brother was detained twice
and he was harassed to the point he had
to quit his job as a geologist leave the
country with his wife and two-year-old
son my father had to sit in a Friday
sermon listening to the Imam containing
condemning woman drivers and calling
them prostitutes amongst
of worshipers some of them are friends
and family from my own father I was
faced with organized deformation
campaign in the local media combined
with false rumors shared and low in
family gatherings in the streets and in
school it all hit me it came into focus
that those kids were not meant to be
rude to my son
they were just influenced by the adults
around them and it wasn't about me and
it wasn't a punishment for taking the
wheel and driving a few miles it was a
punishment for daring to challenge the
society's rules but my story goes beyond
this moment of truth of mine allow me to
give you a very brief in about my story
it was May 2011 and I was complaining to
a work colleague about the harassments I
had to face trying to find a ride back
home although I have a car and
international driver's license as long
as I know woman in Saudi Arabia have
been always complaining about the bank
but it's been 20 years since anyone
tried to do anything about it a whole
generation ago he broke the good bad
news in my face but there is no law
banning you from driving I looked it up
and he was right there was an actual law
inside Arabia it was just a custom and
traditions that are enshrined in rigid
religious fet was an important woman
that realization ignited the idea of
John 17 when we encouraged women to take
the wheel and broad drive
it was a few weeks later we started
receiving all these men walls with Rabia
if you go and drive a courageous woman
her name is Lesley Hariri she's assigned
a woman in the city of Jeddah she drove
a car and she announced but she didn't
record a video we needed proof so I
drove I posted a video on YouTube and
for my surprise it got hundreds of
thousands of views the first day what
happened next
of course I started receiving threats to
be killed rape just
stop this campaign the Saudi authorities
remained very quiet
that really creeped us out I was in the
campaign with other side a woman and
even men activists we wanted to know how
the authorities will response when the
actual day June 17 with women go out and
drive so this time I asked my brother to
come with me and drive by a police car
it went fast
we're arrested sign a plate not to drive
again released arrested again he was
sent to detention for one day and I was
sent to jail I wasn't sure why I was
sent there because it didn't face any
charges in the interrogation but what I
was sure of of my innocence I didn't
break a law and I kept my abaya it's a
black clock we were in Saudi Arabia
before we leave the house and my fila
prisoners kept asking me to take it off
but I was so sure of my innocence I kept
saying no I'm leaving today outside the
jail the whole country went to into a
frenzy some attacking me badly and
others supportive and even collecting
signatures for in a petition to be sent
to the king to release me I was released
after nine days June 17 comes the the
streets were packed with police cars and
religious police cars but some hundred
brave sandy woman broke the ban and
drove that day none were arrested
we broke the taboo
so I think by now everyone knows that we
can drive or women are not allowed to
drive in Saudi Arabia but maybe few
knows why allow me to help you answer
this question
there was this official study that was
presented to the Shura Council
it's the consultative council appointed
by the king in Saudi Arabia and it was
done by a local professor a university
professor
he claims it's done based on a UNESCO
study under steady States the percentage
of rape adultery illegitimate children
even drug abuse prostitution in
countries with warming drive is higher
than countries we were in don't drive I
know I was like this I was shocked I was
like we are the last country in world
when women don't drive so if you look at
the map of the world that only leaves
two countries Saudi Arabia and the other
Society is the rest of the world we
started a hashtag on Twitter marking the
study and he made headlines around the
world and only the Nvidia Waze is so
empowering to mark your oppressor it
strips it away of his strongest weapon
fear this system is based on ultra
conservative traditions and customs deal
with moment as they are inferior and
they need a guardian to protect them so
they need to take permission from this
garden with a verbal or written all
their lives were minors until the day we
die and it becomes worse when it's
enshrined in religious fete was based on
wrong interpretation of the Sharia law
or the religious laws what's worst when
they become codified as laws in the
system and when women themselves belief
in that infinity and they even fight
those who try to question these rules so
for me it wasn't only about these
attacks I had to face it was about
living two totally different perception
of my personality of my person the
villain back in my home country and the
hero outside
just to tell you two stories happen in
the last two years one of them is when I
was in jail I'm pretty sure when I was
in jail everyone so titles and the
international media something like this
during these nine days I was in jail but
in my home country it was totally
different picture it was more like this
manali she faces charges of disturbing
public order and inciting women to drive
I know
Manal al-sharif withdraws from the
campaign okay this is my favorite Manal
al-sharif breaks down and confesses
foreign forces incited me and it goes on
even trial and flogging me in public so
it's not a different picture
I was asked last year to give a speech
and also Freedom Forum I was surrounded
by this love on supportive people around
me and they looked at me as an
inspiration the same time I flew back to
my home country they hated that speech
so much the way they call it a betrayal
to the sided country undecided people
and they even started a hashtag called
also traitor on Twitter some ten
thousand tweets were written in that
hashtag while the opposite hashtag Oslo
hero
there was like handful of twists written
they even started a poll more than
thirteen thousand voters answered this
poll whether they consider me a traitor
or not after the speech ninety percent
said yes she's a traitor
so it's these two totally different
perception of my personality for me I'm
a crowd side a woman and I do love my
country and because I love my country
I'm doing this because I believe a
society will not be free if woman of
that society are not free
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you but you learn lessons from
these things that happen to you
Elaine to be always there the first
thing I got out of jail
of course after I took a shower I went
online I opened my Twitter account on my
Facebook page and I've been always very
respectful to those people who are open
it to me I would listen to what they say
and I would never defend myself with act
with words only I would use actions when
they said I would draw from the kambei I
found the first lawsuit against the
General Directorate of traffic police
for not issuing me a driver's license
there are a lot of people also very big
supportive like those 3,000 people who
signed the petition to release me like
the we sent a petition to the Shura
Council in favor of lifting the ban on
side the woman and the read like 3,500
citizens believes in that and they
signed that petition there are people
like that I just showed some sample who
are amazing who are believing in women's
rights in Saudi Arabia and trying and
they're also facing a lot of hate
because of speaking up and voicing their
views Saudi Arabia today is taking small
steps toward enhancing women's rights
the Shura Council that's appointed by
the king by royal decree from King
Abdullah last year there were 30 women
assigned to that council like 20% 20% of
the council the same time finally that
council after rejecting our petition
four times per room in driving they
finally accepted it last February
after being sent to jail or since his
lashing or sent to a trial the
spokesperson of the traffic police said
we will only issue traffic violation for
women drivers
the grand masti was the head of the
religious establishment in Saudi Arabia
he said it's not recommended for women
to drive used to be haram forbidden by
the previous Grand Mufti so for me it's
not about all these small steps
it's about warming themselves a friend
once asked me she said so what do you
think this woman driving will happen I
told her only if women stopped asking
when and take action to make it now so
it's not only about the system it's also
about us woman to drive our own life I'd
say so I have no clue really how I
become an activist and I don't know how
I became one now but all I know and all
I'm sure of in the future when someone
ask you mama
ask me my story I will say I'm proud to
be amongst this woman who lived the ban
Ford the ban and celebrated everyone's
freedom so the question I started my
talk with who do you think is more
difficult to face oppressive governments
or oppressive societies I hope you find
clues to answer that from my speech
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you